on to our coverage of the coronavirus a  new mask  requirement will take effect right at  midnight here in clark county  it's the result of a vote by the clark  county commission  all in an effort to address rising covet  cases and low vaccination rates here  locally  it affects employees whenever they're  indoors in public places  even if they're vaccinated local  businesses are being asked to post  new signage recommending everyone to  mask up before going indoors  well i'm a little disheartened that  we've come this far and we're  it feels like we're taking a little step  back i'm glad that we don't have to  you know argue this point with our  customers yet i hope it doesn't get that  far  commissioners are also requiring major  companies and larger venues to submit a  coven mitigation plan by next monday  the new requirement lasts nearly a month  that's when the county will revisit  covid numbers